parkland survivor David Hogg goes after
Laura engrams advertiser's the media
seek to bar conservatives on any grounds
possible and we check the mailbag i'm
ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
alright well we have a lot to get to I
want to talk a lot about what's been
going on with Laura Ingraham and this
Astroturf boycott by Media Matters and
why it has nothing to do with civility
or distance II and has everything to do
with politics we'll go through all of it
in just one second first I want to say
thank you to our sponsors over at policy
genius so life insurance is one of those
things that you really don't like
thinking about you don't like talking
about it because it suggests that one
day you're gonna die well I have news to
break to you we all will and when that
day comes you want to make sure that
your family is taking care of four out
of ten people in the United States do
not have life insurance you might be one
of those people but life insurance rates
right now are the lowest they have been
in twenty years and the best place to
buy is policy genius calm in just five
minutes you can compare quotes from over
15 life insurance providers and when you
compare quotes you're gonna get a better
product a cheaper product that's how
competition works
policy genius has helped over 4 million
people shop for insurance and placed
over 20 billion dollars in coverage
they don't just insure life of course
they insure everything else they insure
health insurance disability insurance
pet insurance renter's insurance all of
it
so if you've been putting off getting
life insurance there's no reason to do
that
like really you shouldn't wait until
something terrible happens and your
family is left in ruins instead you
should insure that they are taken care
of go to policy genius com get quotes
apply in minutes it is that easy you get
it taken care of in half an hour and
you're done you can do it right now
their rates are their lowest in 20 years
right policy genius.com it's the easy
way to compare and buy life insurance
just takes a couple of minutes and you
can get it done policy genius.com the
best way to ensure that your family is
safe and secure in case something
terrible should happen again policy
genius.com
all right so the big story over the last
24 hours has been that many advertisers
have now dropped at laura ingraham show
on fox news and the reason they dropped
laura ingraham show is because she
tweeted something out yesterday which we
discussed in which she suggested i'm
gonna quote her directly she said david
hog rejected by four colleges to which
he applied and whines about it we played
the clip of david hog who is the
Parkland shooting survivor who's
obviously made a name for himself saying
pretty vicious things on television
about Second Amendment advocates Dana
lash Gio Peters he's he's been pretty
brutal to everyone who disagrees with
him and he's wanted to have it both ways
David hog and again there's not a
criticism of his right to speak
obviously he has the right to speak and
he should speak however much you want
and this isn't a criticism of his status
as a survivor
obviously something awful that never
should
happened to anybody of decency happened
to David Hagen that's awful and
unforgivable but he's now in the
political debate and that means that
there's some slings and arrows that come
with the political debate I know this
okay when I was 17 years old the same
age as David hog I started writing a
syndicated column and I got clubbed
about the ears for it and a lot of that
was deserved because guess what at 17
you don't know everything and sometimes
your perspectives are wrong and if you
join in the political debate then it is
open season on your politics and by the
way it's not to not to be liked insults
are bad people saying silly stupid
things about you that's that's nasty but
it does happen on a relatively regular
basis okay for years I was called the
virgin been in the left-wing press okay
that is not a joke from the time I was
17 there there were people who were
calling me the virgin bed because
obviously I was a nerd who had never had
sex and I was proud about the fact that
I hadn't had sex and I was a virgin
until I was married but I was called the
virgin Ben not once did I ever call for
the people who are calling me the virgin
Ben to lose their advertising base and
my retaliatory response was always okay
let's talk about ideas or you're an
idiot
okay that's the way that politics works
David hog however called immediately for
an advertiser boycott on Laura Ingraham
and all these advertisers complied a lot
of advertisers comply with this stuff
because they're afraid that they don't
really want the controversy they're
concerned that any controversy
associated with their product is gonna
hurt their sales the reality is these
boycotts don't really work very well
when they tried to an actual boycott
against chick-fil-a for example it
failed immediately and I remember just a
few weeks ago months ago when Karen
Coffey was was bullied into dropping
Sean Hannity as an advertiser Sean
fought back and Keurig reinstated their
advertisement within like a week so all
this talk about advertiser is really
feeling the impact of politics it's just
not true people don't not buy products
because they don't like the the programs
that advertisers advertise on right
secondary boycotts generally do not work
that's worth noting but one of the
questions I want to ask here is what is
this boycott against Laura really about
she's come out and apologized now so if
you said that it was about civility if
you said it's about decency she
shouldn't have said what she said I
don't think she should have said what
she said either right so that yesterday
on the show but if you think this
boycott is about civility or decency you
got another thing coming because now
she's apologized okay
status quo ante restored right we're all
supposed to be cordial with the parkland
survivors which we should be we should
be decent with the Parkland survivors
which we should be I have been
very focused on doing that throughout
this entire entire horrible mess that's
happened in the aftermath of an even
more horrible horrible incident
obviously but decent use restored right
well not right because after Laura
Ingraham apologized David hog said I
want to continue to boycott Laura
Ingraham Ray said I want to continue to
boycott Laura Ingraham so here is hog
rejecting Laura Ingram's apology that
they cannot push us around especially
when we're all we're trying to do here
is save lives and when people try to
distract like Laura's trying to do right
now from what the real issue here is
which is gun violence in America it's
not only sad it's just wrong from a
journalistic standpoint I would say that
she needs to be more objective and needs
to stand down because I am not the issue
here
the issue needs to be gun violence in
America but what she's trying to do is
to distract from that ok well the boy
okay first of all I seriously doubt that
David hog hates the attention I think
that you know when it comes to him
pushing a boycott that's that's
successfully working I think against
luring rooms advertisers I really doubt
that David hog laments that and and as
far as who's taking us off focus on the
gun control stuff you know none of this
has to do with gun control or shouldn't
said what she said hog shouldn't have
made an issue out of it it's really like
none of this really has to do with gun
control or saving lives pretty clearly I
don't know what he means when he says
that Laura should be more objective
she's obviously conservative and she
says so even Allison camerata jumps in
at that point and says well she's not an
objective
host that's not him just rejecting her
apology here's its clip three where hug
rejected Ingram's apology he said I 100%
agree in apologies and effort just to
save your advertisers is not enough I
will only accept your apology only if if
you denounce the way your network has
treated my friends and I in this fight
it's time to love thy neighbor not
mudslinging children okay so this tweet
is really telling okay what hog is doing
here is wildly inappropriate first of
all he doesn't have to accept our
apology you never have to accept an
apology but if we're gonna pretend that
this is some sort of principled non
acceptance of an apology it is it is
clearly not right when he says the Emma
knees thanking he's thanking all of the
advertisers that are dropping Laura
Ingraham because he likes the fact that
he's wielding this sort of power against
Ingram for engaging in what is by any
sort of political standard rather mild
stuff ray he's tweeting at her
hashtag shut up and be objective and be
objective it go back to the original
tweet for just a second
the first one right so he's when he says
here it's time to love thy neighbor not
mudslinging at children two things that
David hog is saying here again none of
this is an attack on hog as a person
right hog might be a fine upstanding
person although I think that his
behavior here is really questionable and
I think that his behavior for the last
couple of weeks in labeling all of his
enemies evil has been really quite vile
but maybe he's it maybe he's a good
person okay he seems like a smart kid
okay but this last line is time to love
thy neighbor not mudslinging children
once you step out in the public debate
and you start speaking publicly on
issues of consequence you no longer get
to hide behind the title child that Kyle
cashew who is a classmate of hogs in any
younger class then David hog right I
don't think the Kyle is Kyle's not a
senior I think he's a sophomore right
Kyle
yeah or junior Kyle came out he said you
don't get to pretend you're a child and
then at the same time say that you're an
adult you ought to be ruling the world
with regards to these policies and when
it comes to David hog saying you ought
to love thy neighbor and that he's
standing up for civility again I'm not
defending Laura's comment I'm not saying
she shouldn't have apologized I am
saying that David hog pretending to be
an advocate of civility is is pretty
astonishing and launching a boycott on
behalf of civility as David hog is
pretty astonishing because here are all
the things that David hog has said just
in the last two weeks about his
political opponents is clip ten pathetic
because I want to keep telling our
children they could have blood from
children splattered all over their faces
and they wouldn't take action because
they all still see those dollar signs
I'm gonna start off by putting this
price tag right here as a reminder for
you guys to know how much Marco Rubio
took for every students life in Florida
one dollar and five cents okay I mean do
you think that's unnecessarily
provocative no I think it's not enough
per bag I don't think it's even
provocative enough when your old parents
like I don't know how to send an
iMessage you know just like give me the
phone sadly that's what we have to do
with our government because our parents
don't know how to use a mock recei so we
have to what Dana's trying to do the I
believe she's the CEO of the NRA she's
trying to distract people if you listen
to her talk she's the national
spokeswoman for the NR exactly she owns
these congressmen she can get them to do
things it's just she doesn't care about
these children's lives it just makes me
think what's sick
they don't want to continue to sell more
guns murder more children and honor so
just get reelected what type of person
are you when you want to see more money
than children's lives how what type of
person does that if you can't get
elected without taking money from child
murderers why are you running with rick
Scott it's like when I get elected to
Senate we're not gonna let that happen
and that's the great thing about it
because those aren't gonna get reelected
when you start hearing from your
political aides that there's a load of
angry future voters you start to worry
okay love the neighbor love that okay
I'm sorry you don't get to play the love
that neighbor card when this has been
your stick for the last couple of weeks
okay you really don't
it just doesn't wash so what's the
boycott really about the boycott of
course is about politics it's about
political opponents of Loras who see an
opening and now they're gonna Club her
right because this is how Media Matters
operates this is how the left operates
with their boycott tactics that if
somebody makes a boo-boo then no apology
is sufficient and they will jump in and
they will attempt to remove your
advertising base and you can see this
from the way that the media continued to
treat this entire issue so over on MSNBC
right the MSNBC panel says that Laura
Ingraham is using she's losing
advertisers over her casual cruelty
right MSNBC is jumping on this because
MSNBC is a Fox News competitor this is
all political to pretend this is not
political is to ignore reality obviously
you don't
business Laura Ingraham because of her
easy and casual cruelty that she
inflicts out on people on a daily basis
and again to John Heilemann point what
you see is another example of an adult
acting terribly okay and what you're
seeing here is what the media have done
and they've been doing this since the
shooting and I object to it what they've
done is they've taken these kids who
really don't necessarily know anything
about gun control they have an evidence
tremendous knowledge about the issue and
they are using them as stand-ins for
their own opinion and then if those kids
opinions are attacked the media jumps
out in front says hey how dare you
attack these kids and the media is
pretty much admitting this right brian
Stelter on CNN says listen we're not
treating these kids as we would treat
any other guest in our program we're not
calling them when they say things that
are blatantly factually erroneous right
he was questioned about this by a c-cup
on CNN Headline News is clip 11 here's
Stelter explaining yeah we don't ask
them real questions we just have them
come out and tried out their political
point of view and then if anybody
attacks their political point of view
then we basically say those people are
bad people when I was interviewing David
hog
ten days after the massacre there were a
few times I wanted to jump in and say
let's let's correct that fact and that
one of the times I did and other times I
did not and you know there's always that
balance because this is a victim out on
one hand who is entitled to his own
emotional response yeah but at the same
time as news people when we hear
something to monstre bleah untrue right
you want to go in and say when you
called a dilash center a CEO interrupted
and corrected that but there are other
times when I think all of us can agree
any of these students at any of these
parents we want everybody to be as well
inform as we can yeah about the the
contours of this debate okay but you
didn't stop this kid when he was out
there saying that Dana lash ran the that
that she ran Congress right you didn't
stop and nobody at Alton Cammarata
didn't stop David Hogg when he went on
the air and he called everybody opposed
him akin to a child murderer
right this is what CNN has done this is
what CNN has been awful on this I said
this directly to brian Stelter last week
right this is nothing that I haven't
said publicly on CNN to CNN so I'm gonna
talk a little bit more about this in
just a second because I think the
ultimate example of this was Allison
Cammarata this morning on CNN I will
show it to you it's pretty egregious
and again this isn't even about Hogg
anymore right Hogg as a kid who was
using a platform that's being given to
him by the media and he seems like a
smart kid he seems like a motivated kid
he also seems like somebody who's saying
things that are deeply immoral and the
media aren't using him as a prop in
order to say those things and I think
that the media are the really
problematic people here I think that
it's quite disgusting what they're doing
but first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at links so do you need a
drink because I do okay well if you do
then wink is the place for you winc it's
a great resource it makes enjoying town
time that much easier and you know even
I enjoyed a glass of wine on occasion
even straight-laced folks like me
certainly people around this office
enjoy getting drunk after the show well
wink makes it he's here doing to ensure
that you can discover great wine most
importantly what wink does you don't
know anything about wine
now you know no wine from Drano but what
you do know is what tastes good and wink
ensures that you can bring a
sophisticated bottle of lines here next
engagement or get the wine at your house
that you actually want because here's
the way it works you fill out the wink
palate profile quiz and you answer
simple questions their average store
clerk wouldn't ask or translate into a
recommendation like how do you like your
coffee and how do you feel about
blueberries in the
winks ins wines curated to your taste
the more wines you rate the more
personalized or monthly selections each
month there are new delicious wines like
the insanely popular summer water rose a
no membership fees skip any month cancel
anytime
shipping is covered and if you don't
like a bottle they send you they'll
replace it with a bottle you will love
no questions asked so discover great
wine today go to try wink calm / Ben
that's t ry winc calm / Ben and you'll
get $20 off your first shipment that's
try winked calm / ban for 20 bucks off
your first shipment t ry winc calm / ben
use that / pens they know that we sent
you again their wines start at like 13
bucks a bottle and it's personalized for
you ship right to your door winc calm
try wink con c ry winc calm / ben you
get $20 off that first order okay so the
worst example of media bias obviously is
CNN and the worst example on CNN has
been Allison camerata he's just been
awful on this she's had on survivor
after survivor all on the left she
wouldn't have on Kyle kasher because
Kyle cash who once tweeted out that CNN
was fake news well speaking of fake news
here was heroes Allison Camerata
questioning David Hogg this morning
about all of this college hubbub so
remember this whole thing started with
with him going on TMZ been talking about
being rejected by four colleges and
handling it pretty decently I thought
except at the very end he said that if
colleges don't want to help us out while
we were still changing the world the
implication being the colleges were
rejecting him for his political
viewpoint which is just asinine ok
cottages I promise you the colleges that
rejected David Hogg did so long before
this happened ok right now if David Hogg
were to reapply probably half the
colleges that didn't let him in would
let him in now Hogg said I mean he said
in the interview I believe that he has a
4.1 GPA and a 1270 1270 SAT which is a
fine score that is not the average score
of the people getting into UCLA
I know that my sister didn't get into
UCLA and she had well into the 1300s in
about a 4.1 GPA so again there there
plenty of reason neutral rationales for
why Hogg didn't get into these
particular colleges and it has nothing
to do with him being stupid or anything
he's not stupid he's obviously again for
the 1,000th time a smart kid but there
are lots of reasons why you wouldn't get
into UCLA with the 1270 with the 1270
average I mean with a 1270 SAT in fact I
want to look up right now the average
SAT score for UCLA at Middies it is it
is certainly not a 1270 right now it it
let's see so let's see I'm looking at
preps caller.com
so according to their admission
statistics the average SAT score average
SAT score composite at UCLA is thirteen
seventy right a full 100 points higher
than then David Hogg so that's why I
didn't get in UCLA it's very selective
college doesn't mean he's not gonna go
to college he will go to college but
watch this clip where Allison camerota
demonstrates that now the media views
these kids as cult figures cult figures
right it's not if anybody if anybody
crosses David Hogg it's not because
maybe there's a reason that they did so
like a value neutral they don't hate
David Hogg reason it must be because
they hate David hog and hate his agenda
I mean this this clip from cammarata
just says so many things in so little
time let's play it David I am stunned
that four colleges rejected you what
kind of dumb colleges don't want you I
mean you've taken the country by storm
okay this is this is insane
okay what kind of dumbass colleges would
reject you
how about colleges that were like just
looking at his scores before any of this
started but again treating these kids as
totems is what this is all about this is
all about treating these kids as totems
and then suggesting that anyone who
crosses these kids must be cast out in
in sackcloth and ashes even though
they're UCLA administrators who are
leftist okay I know the administrators
at UCLA they are leftists this is so
silly by the way if you think the david
hog is a victim of the colleges forget
about what happened to parkland if you
think that a white middle class kid
upper middle class kid from from
parkland Florida hey sis white male
right a white privileged kid according
to it let's put this right if Kyle if
the shooting had not taken place in
parkland and they were talking right now
about the admissions for this guy would
they really be suggesting that the
colleges had discriminated against him
or would they suggest that if he got
into UCLA he'd be taking a spot that
better go to an ethnic kid with a bad
background with a hard background
apparently sis privilege goes right out
the window as soon as a political agenda
is at stake this is about the media it
really isn't about these kids these kids
are saying what they're saying because
they're on camera and because they're
kids and I don't blame them for that I
do blame the media for for making them
totems that can never be crossed under
any circumstances okay so yesterday I
had the opportunity to sit down with
Thomas ol and I wanted to bring that to
you because it was really cool Thomas
soul is of course one of the foremost
economists in America he's it
thinker and more importantly Thomas soul
is I think a a real ethical guide for a
lot of folks because he thinks about
issues rational he has a brand new book
out I had a chance to sit down with him
yesterday here's what it sounded like
welcome to the show Thomas Sol the
leading economist in the United States
and one of the great thinkers of the
modern American scene has a brand new
book out it's called discrimination and
disparities I had the pleasure of
reading it over the last couple of weeks
I've actually referenced it at least
twice on the show since I read it I
think it's quite brilliant professor
solo thanks so much for joining us so
let me let me start with what I think is
the most important part of the book you
make an argument with regard to the
definition of discrimination because
people tend to lump all sorts of
discrimination together you talk about
discrimination 1 1 B and discrimination
- can you just explain what those are
and what the difference is between them
yeah people who have discriminating
tastes meaning that they are very good
at comparing things and making decisions
accordingly discrimination 2 means
almost the opposite namely that once
you've identified someone's identity
then that person's individual qualities
don't matter you will treat them
negatively but on the basis of that and
it's discrimination - that it
discriminate anti-discrimination laws
have been passed to deal with and
discrimination 1 B is a different type
of discrimination that you discuss as
well this would be the use of group data
in order to make individual decisions in
the absence of individual information is
that right that's right criminais ssin 1
a would be judging each person as
individual 1 B would be judging
individuals by the group that they come
from in the absence of hi call
information that we have a prohibitive
call and the reason that distinction is
so important you talk about it in the
book is because what people tend to do
is lump all of these things together so
if you for example our taxi driver in
New York City and there's a higher crime
rate in the black community and so you
don't pick up a particular black
customer people accuse you of being a
racist as opposed to simply you're using
the information available to you and the
proper solution to that would be the
uber or lyft solution where you can
actually profile the criminal
backgrounds and potential customers
presumably yes black taxi drivers do
that
white taxi driver so professor so one of
the things that's great about the book
and I think the most important thing is
that you point out that just because
there are disparities between racial
groups which is of course the most
important thing people talk about in the
country that doesn't necessarily mean
that there's some sort of vicious
discrimination going on there could be
an informational based discrimination
one be going on there could be a
behavioural discrimination type one
going on how is it that we should
approach separating out the types of
discrimination that are that are really
insidious from from the other types of
discrimination when we just see a
headline in the newspaper that says
black folks have fewer homes than white
folks or black folks are committing more
crimes than white folks for example well
I think the crucial implicit assumption
is that in the absence of discrimination
and in the absence of any genetic
differences that people would be more or
less randomly or equally spread out and
therefore there wouldn't be these
differences in point of fact there are
innumerable differences one of the
simplest ones that gets ignored all the
time is that groups have different ages
that is the Japanese Americans have a
median age that is 20 years older than
the median age of mexican-americans and
so if you're talking about jobs that
require you know either long years of
education or 10 years of experience
something like that then just the
demographic differences means you have
no chance from the outset even if
Japanese Americans and Mexican Americans
were absolutely identical with every
other aspect and one of the things that
this makes clear your discussion of this
discrimination your book discrimination
and disparities and the differences
between groups one of the things this
makes clear is that virtually all
government programs that are directed at
direct redistribution between groups are
probably bound to fail because they're
not taking into account the real reasons
for the disparities in the first place
so the book is discrimination and
disparities professor so obviously is
written a number of books I've
recommended probably 10 to 15 books on
the program already his latest is really
timely and really effective professor so
one final question for you because I
know that we're a little short on time
there wasn't your time study that came
out a couple of weeks ago and the claim
from the New York Times is that it
showed that black boys particularly are
facing discrimination in the United
States that black girls are not and that
among rich households even
income is not a good predictor of future
performance the suggestion from the New
York Times that America is just more
racist against black boys than black
girls what was your take on that study
if you had a chance to look at it but I
see no reason whatever it wants you to
expect boys and girls to behave the same
any more than we would expect you know
japanese-americans to be highly highly
represented in baseball when when their
median age was in the upper 40s again
the book is discrimination and
disparities professor song thanks so
much for taking the time I really do
appreciate it it's always a pleasure to
have you tell he's an honor and we
always appreciate that you take the time
to be on the program oh thank you thanks
so much well in just a second we are
going to get to some some other issues
with regard to how the left is utilizing
power in order to keep conservatives out
of media I haven't really discussed in
depth a Kevin Williamson issue over at
Lee Atlantic I want to talk about that a
little bit plus I want to get to the
your questions in the mailbag we'll do
it a little bit early today but first I
want to say thank you to a brand new
sponsor okay these guys are awesome
this is boro boro has reinvented the
luxury couch from style to shipping
functionality to adaptability Burrell
has put the time and thought into buying
furniture so you do not have to so
here's how it works you go over to
Borough bu rrow dot-com / Ben Shapiro
you get 75 bucks off your order and what
they are there they're fantastic
fantastic couches and loveseat and
chairs and they all fit together right
mean this is how it works so the borough
is adaptable so if your space changes
they have modular design it allows it to
move and grow with you all borough
furniture it shipped fast shipping is
free set up is really easy as is moving
it again so you never have to worry
about it being too heavy or being clunky
okay all the furniture is is fantastic
also it has stain resistant fabric so if
you got kids or pets again you're
worried about the thing looking bad
after a week now the stuff is gonna look
good for a lit for a long time because
it is the stain-resistant fabric plus it
had something really cool if you're
somebody like me and you're sitting on
the couch working at night watching
Netflix at the same time there's a
built-in USB charger into the into the
furniture which is pretty amazing Boro
has the durability and functionality to
keep up with your hectic life and enjoy
30 days of cozy on your burro risk-free
so you try it you don't like it no
problem or try out burrow at one of
their showrooms today we already have
Bernal on our house and I think I'm
gonna go buy another one just from my
home office because the furniture really
is spectacular it's bu
ro w comm / ben shapiro so the code here
is ben shapiro beat u rrow comm / ben
shapiro and when you use that you get 75
bucks off your order again all the
furniture is great-looking and it fits
together so if you buy you want a
smaller couch now but you want to be
bigger later tell modular so you can
actually buy furniture that allows for
the addition of new furniture and makes
the couch bigger it's just it's really
cool in every way go check it out right
now
bu rrow comm / ben shapiro again bu ro w
GM / bench but it also makes it really
easy to move you don't have to try and
shift that ten-foot couch through the
doorway pivot pivot like in front you
don't have to do that instead you get
these these modular designs and they
last and they're great they are anti
that they can take on your pets claws I
mean this is this is something they
pitch bu rrow comm / ben shapiro 75
bucks off your purchase go check it out
right now honestly really affordable
fantastic furniture that's gonna last
and it's easy to move it's just great
check it out alright so if the laura
ingraham boycott is really more about
politics than it is about decency or
civility which clearly it is i mean
obviously this is about it's not about
decency it's not about civility if it
were then everybody would be saying okay
Lord and I said what she said and David
hog should not be saying what he says
and by the way other folks should not be
saying what they say so I want to show
you some video of an actor who is
attacking Laura Ingraham this guy is I'm
trying to remember his name this is
Michael Rapaport so you've seen him in
you've seen him in in various TV shows
you'll recognize he's well those guys we
just recognize his face
here he goes attacking Laura Ingraham is
he gonna lose a single job for attacking
a woman like this of course not here's
Michael Rapaport Laura Ingraham the Fox
News reporter you filthy Pig
you dog-faced animal remember Laura
Ingraham just a year ago at the
Republican National Convention throwing
up the Nazi salute look at this check
this out look look at the Aryan pin-up
girl and now Laura Ingraham dis Savage
this dog this mutt and this has nothing
to do with her looks it has to do with
her behavior the things that she exudes
she's a sweaty pig she's going after
this high school student okay so this
guy again was this about civility or
decency I miss the part where this is
about civility and decency
because supposedly what
great cinemas was not being civil to
these kids right not being decent to
these kids but this has never been about
civility or decency this has always been
about power and the use of power in
order to shut down opposing points of
view but people don't like what Laura
had to say and so they're attacking
Laura's business that's that's what they
are doing right now and it really is
pretty gross especially after she
apologized but that's not unusual
because what the less is also trying to
do is say that Kevin Williamson can't
work at the Atlantic so Kevin Williamson
is very conservative he's libertarian in
orientation
he was also extraordinarily anti Trump
like more anti Trump than anyone else
probably on the right and the Atlantic
decided to hire him away from national
review hey and so what the left did is
they dug through all the millions of
words that he'd written and they found
something they didn't like and they said
he should not be allowed to write for
our publications because that would just
be terrible there are two op-eds out
today about Kevin Williamson and the
Atlantic from left as saying here's why
Kevin Williamson should not be allowed
to write for us now the only people that
the left will accept writing for them
are people who openly disagree with
large planks of the Republican platform
and the conservative platform at this
point first of all if you voted for
Trump forget it you will never work for
a mainstream publication it's just not
going to happen even the supposedly
conservative people who work for the
mainstream publications our
conservatives who do not who did not
vote for Trump right those people are
welcomed into the into particular
circles in the mainstream media
specifically because they didn't write
Bret Stevens can write for The Wall
Street Journal and then move over to the
New York Times the New York Times says
it's okay for him to be over there
because he didn't vote for Trump
obviously even Bret Stevens was ripped
up and down for being too conservative
they're doing the same thing to Kevin
Williamson over at the Atlantic even
though he's the biggest Trump critic in
the world Michelle Goldberg who writes
for the New York Times
even though she's egregiously awful I
mean all of her columns are just sheer
garbage here here's what she writes
although I'm a squishy hearted liberal I
have a soft spot for dyspeptic
reactionaries like HL Mencken and V s
Naipaul men they're almost always men
speak to a dark misanthropic corner of
my soul thus I've occasionally read
Kevin Williamson a truly vicious but
sometimes bracing writer when he was at
National Review where his words
resonated with me it would make me aware
of hidden currents of cruelty in my own
thinking I grew up in a conservative
Rust Belt suburb and hated it and I
loathe populist sanctimony that treats
my stultifying hometown is more
authentically American than the vibrant
city I escaped to so I feel a guilty
shudder of satisfaction reading
williamson's vituperative 2016 attack on
his functional small towns that
supported Donald Trump the way
williamson's contempt spoke to me made
me think about how my fury over Trump's
rise in my devotion
cosmopolitanism was curdling into the
very elitism people like me are
constantly accused of the ability to
prompt such an comfortable self
recognition is a good quality and a
polemicist so I almost understand why
the Atlantic magazine seeking to add a
provocative right-wing voice to its Russ
roster recently hired Williamson okay
there isn't so in other words she likes
Williamson because she realized that
Williamson is evil and when she reads
Williams and agrees with him it's
because she was realizing her own evil
great way to start a piece there Michele
yeah you're obviously very into
ideological diversity at the Atlantic
and then she goes on and describes white
as the William shouldn't be at once and
shouldn't be allowed to work for the
Atlantic she says it's just terrible
they've done the same thing now to Barry
Weiss at the New York Times they've done
the same thing too to various other
conservatives who've been hired by
mainstream at publications it's just
it's it's just absurd it's just absurd
and there's another piece in The
Huffington Post that is called bad ideas
aren't worth debating with a giant
picture of course of Kevin Williamson
and talking about how nobody who has
ever had a bad idea should ever be
allowed to write for an institution like
the Atlantic now listen if the Atlantic
wants to be left wing National Review
that's fine but the Atlantic is trying
not to do that they are purporting to be
a in house an in-house place for very
for a variety of opinion for various
modes of debate hey listen I'm not
hiring anybody on the left over it daily
we're but we're very clear about that
right it's not ideological because it's
ideological like I'm not gonna hire
tonic ICI coats over here at the Daily
wire number one cuz I can't afford him
but number two because I disagree with
him but the Atlantic is saying that they
want a wide variety of opinion the folks
on the Left don't want a wide variety of
opinion the folks on the Left want no
variety of opinion right their goal is
to have no opinion variety at all that
is the point and that is why they don't
want Kevin Williamson involved in any of
this that is that is the entire goal
here the entire goal here is to have no
conservatives involved at all okay I'm
gonna get to the mailbag in just a
second first I want to say thank you to
our sponsors over at trippin comm so
trippin comm best place to plan a
vacation you need a vacation you have a
family one of the hardest things in life
is finding a hotel room that can fit
your family so don't worry about it
anymore go get a vacation rental
vacation rentals are so much better
honestly this is something my family and
I discovered ourselves is that when you
go and you rent a place with a couple of
bedrooms and you put the kids in one and
you're in the other your life is just
better ed you have a washer and a dryer
you don't have to pack 80,000 pieces of
clothing all of that is just the best
that's why you need trippin comm okay go
over trippin comm you're planning a
spring break on the beach in Florida you
want to swim in Lake Tahoe in the summer
you want to sit in them of Smokey
Mountains
trippin comm is for you onesearch lets
you compare every home from the world's
top vacation rental sites in one place
to find the best deal on your perfect
vacation rental vacation rentals do
offer more and best of all at tripping
calm you can drain the millions of
travelers to find more savings with
rates up to 80% less than traditional
hotel rooms trippin comm slash Shapiro
that's t RI PP ing comm slash Shapiro
use trippin comm slash capiro find your
perfect vacation rental again vacation
rentals are significantly better than
anything you're gonna get in a hotel you
don't want to be stuck in that in that
100 200 foot square or square foot place
with eight kids instead get the vacation
rental
enjoy yourself spread out it's a home
away from home that's what trippin makes
happen for cheaper and faster than any
place else trippin comm t RI PP ing comm
slash up hero use the slash up hero so
they know that we sent you okay so we
are now going to get to the mailbag so
this is a good time for you to subscribe
to watch you're gonna have to go over to
daily wire.com anyway
well if you want to watch live you may
as well subscribe and you know ask the
questions so go over to daily we're calm
right now $9.99 a month gets you a
subscription to daily wire when you get
that subscription you get the rest of my
show live you get to be part of the
mailbag plus our next episode of the
conversation is coming up next Tuesday
April 10th at 5:30 p.m. Eastern 2:30
p.m. Pacific if you haven't yet joined
the conversation series it's our monthly
Q&A hosted by Alicia Kraus where we
answer any and all questions from
politics to the personal this month
episode features Andrew Clavin it will
stream live on daily where's YouTube and
Facebook pages it will be free for
everyone to watch but only subscribers
can actually ask the questions to ask
questions as a subscriber
while getting to our website daily
wire.com head over to the conversation
page to watch the live stream and after
that just start typing into the daily
wired chat box and I'll answer questions
as they come in for an entire hour so
once again you have to subscribe for
that get your questions answered by
Andrew Klavan Tuesday April 10th 5:30
p.m. Eastern 2:30 p.m. Pacific
join the conversation he will answer
your questions live for an entire hour
and right now you want to be part of the
mailbag get your questions answered now
go put your credit card in and then I'll
answer your questions also if you get
this we want this you want this mug
right this magic tumbler which is better
than any of its competitors yes I'm
listening to you louder with Crowder
fans it is better than the mugs over
there
get this $9.99 a month forget that 99
bucks a year
cheaper than a monthly fee you got all
of those various glories when you get a
subscription if you just want to listen
later go over to iTunes SoundCloud
YouTube please subscribe please leave us
a review it always helps us we are the
largest fastest growing conservative
show in the nation
all righty so let's jump into the
mailbag so David says dear friend from
what abend from one fan to another happy
opening day what is your realistic
expectation for the White Sox this year
well I'm excited enough about my White
Sox this year that I actually went out
and got a subscription to MLB TV and I
watched their opening day game in the
background while I did my work they hit
six home runs yesterday Matt Davidson
had three in one game which is just
awesome realistically maybe an outside
shot at the wild-card maybe I think
maybe eighty eighty-five wins yeah maybe
they get day 87 win something like that
that's if everything goes right if
everything goes wrong then in two years
the limit world series because they have
a really good young core they have a
bunch of players who are coming up from
the minors but their team that's
probably two years away but teams that
have been two years away have
outperformed before look at the Houston
Astros who weren't really expected to
win anything until maybe a couple of
years from now although Sports
Illustrated had it right on the money
Tyler says how do you atone for sins and
Judaism big fan so okay so here's how
you atone for sins in Judaism you tone
really I mean we have like an entire day
for it it's called Yom Kippur where we
spend the entire day fasting and praying
to God to atone now if you sin between
yourself another human being you have to
ask those other human beings for
forgiveness okay and you have to ask
them three separate times at least
before God can even consider whether he
ought to forgive you you ask for
forgiveness every day three times a day
in Judaism so you know before I come
into the show I dive in what's called
chakras ok chakras is the morning
service and in that service there's an
entire paragraph in what's called the
silent I me now there's part of the
service that's silent you stand there
and you're talking directly to God it's
kind of the most intimate part of the
service and there's part called
slackline whoo right it's all about God
forgiving us okay we do that three times
a day so Judaism is all about the
forgiveness and the way you are forgiven
is you have to also commit to not make
the same mistake again so it's not
enough to just say Christianity is the
same way as I understand it it's not
enough to say I'm sorry for that bad
thing that I did you also said that you
also have to say I understand my sin I'm
not gonna do that again in order for God
to consider it Justin says dear Ben what
would you think about a Rand Paul or a
Ted Cruz primary Trump in 2020 if Trump
doesn't get his act together I think
that the possibility of a of a primary
against a sitting US president is very
very risky for the party I think that it
probably tears the party apart I don't
see any of those people beating Trump in
a primary I think they know that which
is why they're not going to try it but a
lot can happen between now and 2020 if
Trump turns out to be
total disaster if things really go to
hell in a handbasket then maybe you
could see a real primary I mean you saw
that in 1968 among Democrats between LBJ
and Eugene McCarthy and in various other
folks so you could see something like
that right the that's why RFK was was
expected to be the nominee in 1968 after
LBJ bowed out but Trump would have to be
a lot worse than he's been if he's just
governs like he has so far there's not
gonna be any primary Nicholas says I've
heard the argument while while debating
why health care shouldn't be considered
right that just as the government grants
you the right to a legal counsel it
could grant you the right to the
services of a health care professional
is that an appropriate analogy or if it
fails in what respects so number one the
idea here is that when the government
arrests you the government has now
placed an onus on you to go to court the
government does not place an onus on you
D at health care that is your decision
and it's not your decision whether you
go to court it is your decision whether
you're gonna get health care and it
should be on your dime whether you get
health care and there is some
significant argument in legal history in
the United States as to whether right to
counsel means that I have to provide you
counsel in my opinion it probably
doesn't it probably means that I have
the right to hire a counsel all right
the public expense doesn't require that
we go out and hire you a counsel but you
know if we are going to hire your
counsel the reason for that is because
we have put you in the system not
through any willpower of your own and
that means we at least have to provide
you with enough of a defense that you
can defend yourself that's not the same
thing as health care where it is up to
you whether you want a doctor or not
well and then this letter continues and
says also I've heard you argue the
health care as a private domain and
they're sure therefore should be kept in
the hands of individuals but there are
certain externalities when it comes to
contagious diseases does that warrant
the government's involvement yes I mean
it depends on the level of the contagion
but yes this is why I'm in favor of
mandatory vaccinations actually it's one
of the areas where I have significant
differences with some more libertarian
minded folks in the in the Republican
party because vaccinations do have
externalities libertarians don't suggest
that you can't regulate for
externalities by the way Jeffrey says
Ben Congrats on landing the radio gay
got an important question though how
will this affect the podcast will
continue as is and the radio show be a
separate thing or will be the pot will
podcast be a rebroadcast of the radio
show well actually the opposite so we're
doing something brand new in radio
history and that is the podcast is the
podcast and then later we take it and
reformat and we use it for radio so the
podcast will sound exactly like it
always has nothing changes about how you
access the podcast or how it sounds it
is not radio that is just you know
repackaged into podcast form with
commercial breaks cut out
thing like that it is the podcast how it
sounds today is how it will sound next
week is how it will always sound mark
says God Emperor Shapiro why I can't
believe that I rested the title away
from Clavin I recall in an episode of
the conversation he said Woodrow Wilson
was likely the most damaging president
in history can you elaborate on why that
is I said the Woodrow Wilson was one of
them probably James Buchanan obviously
up there
LBJ is up there Woodrow Wilson was
seriously damaging because he completely
shifted the way that people thought
about the workings of American
government
so before Woodrow Wilson American
government had based on foundational
principles like eternal immutable rights
protected by limited government that's
what America was about Woodrow Wilson
based on the thoughts of German
progressivism literally writing about
Woodrow Wilson this week in my book
Woodrow Wilson thought completely
differently he thought that the
Declaration was antiquated there was no
such thing as an immutable right as an
unalienable right instead there were
just wise men in the bureaucracy who
could decide for you how to live right
and that the president ought to be as
big a man as possible it's a direct
quote from Woodrow Wilson in order to
sort of embody the general will this
Russo Lee in general well that
unfortunately has become the way the
government is done okay the idea of
foundational limited government that
protects your immutable rights that has
gone by the wayside and the idea of a
bureaucratic regime run by the wisest
and best among us has taken hold among
entirely the Democratic Party and
probably large swathes of the Republican
Party as well he's really damaging that
way also his his intervention in World
War one was was late or he shouldn't
have done it
you know but in any case is there their
questions about when we should have
intervened in World War one let's put
into that and the way that he used World
War one as a club to who to club his
political opponents into submission is
pretty incredible go read liberal
fascism by jonah goldberg
he talks at length about the fact that
Woodrow Wilson came very close to being
the first fascist president in the
history of the United States John says
Ben do you still have time to play the
violin
how the answer is lately no cuz I've
been practice traveling so much but I
did get myself an amazing violin so I
don't spend a lot of money I'm pretty
frugal but I went out and I splurged I
got myself a really really nice violent
and this thing is magnificent and I have
a nice piano in my house a grand piano
my dad plays piano so he comes over we
play Brahms together so the answer is
yes he'll one of my dreams we're trying
to make it happen I want to play Brahms
with Condoleezza Rice I just think this
would be an amazing life experience I
loved interview or two
but had more being more interested in
playing Brahms because she's a really
good pianist and I'm a pretty good
violinist Blake says hi Ben what are
your thoughts on Crowder's impression of
you and well I think that Crowder makes
me out to be a little less personable
than I am in his impression but let's
put it that way I'm a little bit hee-hee
his impression is sort of on the autism
spectrum is that fair
mathis yeah yeah I think that that's
sort of that sort of what he does but
it's it but I get a kick out of it I
think that Crowder is hysterical and I
think when he makes fun of me and does
all of his parodies I yeah crowd was
really nice about this he always lets me
know that he's gonna do these parodies
beforehand and gets my permission said
he's not saying anything that I would
find offensive and invariably I would do
whatever he wanted I trust you you're
really funny Josh does hey man there's a
fellow comic book fan what are your top
three comic book movies of all time I
thought you gonna say comic books of all
time which we can do another time top
three comic book movies of all time well
I mean all three of the Batman movies
all the reading the Nolan movies but
others that are in the mix I really
liked the original Superman x-men first
class is really excellent try and
remember some of the others that are
good I think you'll put Logan up near
the top I did like Logan but I liked the
first 2/3 of it a lot I saw the last
third of it sort of fell apart
mmm there's so many of them now it's
hard for me to come up with my list I
actually did come up with a list at one
point I'll have to look it up but I
believe that that was something close to
the list by the way I like Black Panther
a lot I mean I told you that I didn't
like the politics of it but I thought it
was really well made in compelling
Bailey says what is your favorite part
of Passover mine is always tricking the
kids into eating lots of horseradish
thanks Amaya that's pretty brutal my
friend you know drinking kids into you
know if you've ever eaten raw
horseradish that sucker burns the
favorite part of Passover the whole
thing is great for kids it's designed
for kids because the whole thing is how
do you teach children and the way that
you teach children is through ritual and
questioning so this morning we we burned
the huh made so this is a one of the
Jewish rituals where you you do a
ceremonial thing you clean out your
entire house so you don't have any more
leaven right I'm Passover because when
the Jews left Egypt they didn't have
time to let the bread rise and it was
matzah and so they just left matzah
that's why we eat matzah on Passover
that's the story so what we do is we
clean our house of all eleven and then
we take the night before we do kind of a
final check of the house for 11 and then
we burn it the next morning to signify
that we've done
completed the task so this morning my
kids were very into that we took them
out into the side of the house and we
and we burned the 11 there was a nice
big fire and they were totally into the
fire my son he's just getting to speak
full sentences and I think his first
full sentence came out this morning and
it was something like I really like the
fire it's nice and I thought oh that's
not great but is it but he's my son is
very end of the ritual Judaism is very
much about ritual it's one of the things
I like about Judaism I think that
religion Sonde's ritual actually it's
hard to train people to be better people
without ritual right Aristotle says this
and Judaism takes it to its extreme I
think I think that the ritual is great
obviously the Haggadah the the retelling
of the Passover story is very much based
on asket having kids ask questions right
the four questions that are asked them
on each trial how's that that whole
thing I think you may have heard of
before they my four girl daughters gonna
sing that tonight it's really cool Alex
says who is more of a conservative
Churchill or Reagan well it depends it
in which in which kind of mode you're
talking in terms of foreign policy
they were probably equivalently
conservative Churchill hated the
Communists he hated the Nazis Reagan
hated the communists in terms of
domestic policy Reagan was much more
conservative than Winston Churchill
because America is much more
conservative generally than Great
Britain
let's see Dillon says what is the legal
argument for allowing certain religious
groups to defy the law while disallowing
it for others I'm in favor of religious
liberties but if we allow one group to
go against the law says a law what is
stopping another group from citing that
case is a reason to do whatever they
want to do ie the case of the Little
Sisters of the Poor fighting Obamacare
birth control rules and then another
group wanting to hold group marriages
and/or child marriages these are just
examples maybe of better ones from more
apt comparison so this is a serious
question it's one of the reasons why I
actually believe that religious liberty
is protected by broader Liberty so to
take an example right now there are a
lot of people who are talking about the
fact that your here's a perfect example
of what you're talking about that people
are asking about so you say a religious
bakery doesn't have to cater to a
same-sex wedding or doesn't have to
serve gay people or something so based
on religious exceptions okay but what if
that person wanted to what wasn't
religious and they just wanted to turn
down service to a black person so my
feeling is you can turn down service to
whomever you want this is not a
religious question it's a liberty
question right religious liberty is
protected not because we have to have
specific carve outs but because the
government should be so small and so non
intrusive that religious people
be allowed to live their lives just like
secular people I don't think that the
Constitution was designed to
discriminate in favor of exceptions for
religious people over secular people I
think the Constitution was designed to
protect against encroachment on Liberty
by the government against anyone
religious or secular the smaller the
government the less the chance that the
government is actually going to encroach
on Liberty so what I would say is
freedom of association is the issue with
regard to Christian Baker's not freedom
of religion I've said this many times on
the program but okay Nathaniel says been
regarding the Second Amendment by the
way just quick note on that this does
not mean that I think every aspect of
discrimination is good I think many much
discrimination is is totally morally
wrong that doesn't mean the government
gets to crack down on it we all
discriminate in our lives in various
ways good and bad I'm not sure that it's
the government's role to determine how I
run my business with regard to my
clientele especially because the market
tends to take care of me if I am too
discriminatory and too awful Nathaniel's
was bent regarding the Second Amendment
I find it concerning that US citizens
aren't allowed more freedom in their
choice of guns for protection for
example how can well our militia
defendants nation against a tyrannical
government that used weapons of mass
destruction if the citizens only have AR
so this is a question that's very often
asked by the left saying well if you say
that the purpose of the Second Amendment
was to protect against government
tyranny shouldn't everybody have a Tang
shouldn't everybody have an f16
shouldn't everybody have a gun no okay
the idea here is that you need the
weaponry that is sufficient to deter
government tyranny and if it came down
to it by the way small arms are a
capable deterrent against even the most
major weaponry because if the less if
the United States government has to
legitimately nuke the state of Texas
that war is never happening it's just
not happening okay so there's that also
the the militia the Texas State National
Guard I believe probably would have
access to nuclear weapons so there's
that as well but as far as private
ownership of firearms the point of
private ownership of firearms is to
deter potential conflicts just like the
point of having nuclear arsenals that
you never have to use it Nikolas says hi
Ben my name is Nick I had a quick
question on how to combat those at my
university who used the argument of look
at all the other countries who have gun
control we need to try it how does one
respond when all the left wants to do is
compare the u.s. to Europe regardless of
the topic here's what you should say you
should say okay fine how about we look
to Europe for guidance on abortion
America has significantly less
restrictive abortion laws than much of
Europe abortion is banned in the second
two trimesters in virtually every
European country and its ban across the
board in several European countries so
it's
they're pretty selective about when they
want to copy Europe and when they don't
I'm not a fan of copying Europe because
I think Europe has gotten it all wrong
for a for a fair bit of time I think
that the last century and a half should
show us that Europe is not worth is not
worth imitating now Amy says hi Ben I
grew up Christian but identify as
agnostic now I have a young son and
really like the Christian community and
moral messages taught in the church
I'd like my son to be introduced to
Christianity for those reasons and I'm
considering going back to church but I
don't want to be a non-believing
interloper do you think would be okay to
take him to church even if I may not
believe everything myself
yes I think you should I think you
should absolutely take your son to
church I think social fabric is
important I think teaching your son is
important now I think that you should
decide what you want to teach your kid I
would not teach my kid agnosticism
because I think that agnosticism is is
the idea that you don't know whether God
is there is something even religious
people feel right religious people
wonder whether God is there and knows
what he's doing but you have to decide
what you want to teach your kid don't
don't confuse your kids don't bring them
to church and then take them home and
say everything you're learning in
churches bunk but I like the I like the
social programs now figure out what you
want to teach your kid and then live
along those lines but I think that
church is the number one social fabric
builder in the United States and the
fact that we've lost that social fabric
is contributing to the dis is
contributing to two serious problems
among individuals and communities as
well okay so now time for a couple of
things that I like and a couple of
things that I hate so things that I like
let's let's do that so a couple number
one I want to recommend dennis prager
his new book that comes out on Monday we
were gonna do an interview this week we
just ran out of time I wanted to a full
hour interview with Dennis about his new
book his new book is a commentary on the
Bible and it's and it's really fabulous
it's called Exodus God slavery and
freedom and it's the rationale Bible
right it's it's an amazing thing that
Dennis got this done he literally takes
exodus verse by verse and then he breaks
down what he thinks is the logic and the
reason behind it and I have some
arguments with Dennis on some of this
stuff but it's really deeply researched
it's really well done and it's worth
reading you should put it by your bed
stand and you should read a little bit
of her and I don't bank a better person
then this is a really profound thinker
and he's writing about the greatest
document in the history of civilization
so it is this is why we're getting a go
pre buy it now and you'll get it you
know in the middle of Passover if you're
Jewish and just after Easter if you're
not so dennis prager or if you're not
Christian then you'll get it in the
middle of your regular week dennis
prager
it's again the name of the book is
Exodus gods slavery and freedom go check
it out on Amazon okay other things that
I like since since tonight begins the
holiday of Passover I think that now is
a good time to to use the best Exodus
music ever no it's not from the Prince
of Egypt although there's some really
good numbers in the Prince of Egypt
maybe we'll have to play one next week I
think next Monday I'll do some some
Prince of Egypt particularly the opening
number deliver us is fantastic in Prince
of Egypt but we'll start the the Exodus
feel with the actual theme you move
music from the movie Exodus the movie in
that great but the theme music Stan
tastic and and here's what the theme to
the movie Exodus sounds like
[Music]
it's by Ernest gold it's it's a
beautiful theme the movie of course is
not actually about the biblical Exodus
it's about the it's about the formation
of the State of Israel based on the Leon
URIs novel of the same name which is a
really good novel so check that out
check out the novel rather than the
rather than the movie because the novel
is much better and the obvious
connections between Passover and the
foundation of the State of Israel are
clear and obvious the entire I mean the
the Seder finishes with us shouting next
year in Jerusalem the reason being the
longtime hope of the Jewish people has
always been a Jewish state in Jerusalem
and that has not changed throughout
history that is the biblical hope always
right okay time for a couple of things
that I hate so everybody's been praising
Rosanna that's all fine and good I
protect Rosanna a little bit earlier
this week but I just want to point out
that if people really believe that the
folks who make rows down the folks in
Hollywood have suddenly warmed and are
being nice to trump supporters that's a
bunch of nonsense here's one of Roseanne
stars talking about why people voted
Trump it is not it is not nice can't
understand it don't know where it comes
from other than you know being I think
it's a it's a couple of issues it's
being either under the thumb of your
husband or it's in it for the election
that was being so offended by Hillary
Clinton and and Bill Clinton's legacy
that you turned on her or feeling
inadequate feeling like how can somebody
be so educated how could somebody have
brought themselves up from their own
experience and and and you know gone to
the top educated herself fought for you
know for rights civil rights and
equality and I think that's threatening
to a lot of women okay this is just
absurd the idea that women are jealous
of Hillary Clinton I promise you there's
not a married woman in America who's
jealous of Hillary Clinton's marriage
that's not the way that works but again
just the idea that Hollywood has
suddenly warmed a Trump supporters is a
bunch of nonsense that Sandra Bernhard
of course who's a wild Lefty okay other
things that I hate so next week they're
releasing Chappaquiddick okay this movie
I've already seen it is phenomenal it's
a very very good movie and it is not
conspiratorial in any way it's a
straight retelling of what happened at
Chappaquiddick with Ted Kennedy it's an
amazing thing that this thing got made
in the first place but there's a story
from variety saying that that there was
push back when they first tried to
produce the film Byron Allen his enter
studio entertainment studios CEO he said
unfortunately there are some very
powerful people who tried to true who
tried to put pressure on me not to
release this movie they went out of
their way to try and influence me in a
negative way I made it very clear I'm
not about to right I'm not about to left
I'm about the truth this is true about
this movie this movie is not political
this is not a rip on Ted Kennedy okay it
actually makes Ted Kennedy look somewhat
sympathetic even though Ted Kennedy
acted like just an enormous piece of
garbage but it doesn't go over the rails
either it doesn't it doesn't make him
out to be an innocent it so show that he
was manipulative and being manipulated
it shows that he was that but but it
does not paint him in a completely
unflattering light now there's a lot to
this movie I'm gonna say my full
analysis in the movie for next week I
got to see a screener of it it's it's
really really well-made it's really well
made and they're very careful to only
stick with the facts cuz after watching
the movie I thought well they didn't
include this and this and this and then
I look back and I looked at the evidence
I said well they did include that cuz it
was a rumor they didn't include rumors
right like all the stuff about him
having an affair with Mary Jo there's no
proof of that so that's not in the movie
what it does show is him leaving Mary Jo
there to drown right so there's a lot to
the movie the fact that Hollywood want
to shut it down again Hollywood is a
lefty town do not trust them to tell
conservative stories without resistance
certainly and this is not a conservative
story it's much more an objective take
on what happened with Kennedy is just
amazing that it took what that haven't
in 69 so it took them 40 49 years to do
that all took was half a century for
them to get around to one of the worst
political scandals in the history of the
United States well done Hollywood all
right so we will be back here next week
and we will be doing so in we're excited
to launch the podcast and a bunch of
radio station so tell your parents to
look out for it or to listen to it on
radio as well we are the largest
conservative podcast in the nation and
now we're bring it to radio very excited
about that have a wonderful weekend have
a great meaningful Passover have a great
meaningful Easter this is the Ben
Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Alex and Garo audio is mixed
by Mike Carmina hair and makeup is by
Joshua Oliveira the Ben Shapiro show is
a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright floor publishing